let's walk up Lori thank you guys so
much and I'm you you might think that
the fact that I have lots of undergrads
working with me is because I'm some
super professor doing some crazy cool
research I assure you that's not the
case you can see why the undergrads want
to work with me from this picture here
is that I go to places with cool animals
and warm tropical climates and palm
trees and you'd be surprised that
undergraduates on spring break if
they're offered the opportunity to go
hang out in a warm tropical climate with
beaches and so on they often say yes so
no it's not not not me but but hopefully
I'll be able to tell you guys a little
bit about what I do today here's the
kind of road map of what I want to get
through kind of want to start a little
bit with an introduction to kind of how
I get into this stuff and then I'm going
to talk to you about why it might make
sense to actually study monkeys if
you're interested in humans I'm not
actually a biologist or animal behavior
researcher I consider myself a
psychologist I actually trained in
psychology and I'm really interested in
humans not monkeys so I'm going to talk
about why it would make sense to go to
these tropical places and study monkeys
if you really care about how people work
and then I'm going to give you three
different test cases where I think we've
learned something about the human mind
by turning to monkeys and those test
cases are going to be looking at what
monkeys know about number whether they
can count and do arithmetic what monkeys
know about minds whether they're good at
thinking about what others are thinking
and most recently some work we've done
looking at why they're monkeys know
something about money and then we'll
sort of wrap up and so on but if you
have questions as you go through
definitely raise your hand and call on
me so that we can stop and go through it
but I want to start with a little bit of
a misnomer because I think folks think
that most of the professor's here at
Yale are kind of these stodgy folks who
end up in lecture hall you know teaching
and buildings like this but perhaps
unlike some of my other colleagues I
leave a bit of a double life because yes
i do this i sort of teaching these kinds
of classrooms it look like this but i
also have the opportunity to head off to
these gorgeous places in part because i
study these populations that don't
necessarily live on college campuses i
study a bunch of different non-human
primates there's one of the nonhuman
primates i study his name is 39 el he's
one of these guys on on our field site
but I took a little bit of a strange
trajectory to get here because this is
something that until you know probably
about 10-15 years ago wasn't even on my
radar at all actually grew up in
sort of big working-class town in
Massachusetts known as New Bedford it's
kind of about the size of New Haven or
even Bridgeport I went to a big urban
public high school where nothing like
the kind of stuff i was i'm doing now
has ever taught to me you know i learned
a little bit of biology i learned a
little bit of science but i didn't even
know that this field existed and it was
actually through the act of going to
lectures when i first started to go to
college that i learned that this field
existed i was sitting in a big lecture
hall much like you guys when i was a
freshman and I heard about the fact that
this work existed the fact that you
could be a person who is interested in
humans and use animals as your model to
get at it and I just found this really
fascinating and it helps that my
undergrad advisor at the time threw up
those pictures of the beautiful tropical
spots and i said i am in and somehow
it's stuck so just be warned that
sitting in a lecture hall like this
might change the course of your life
where you end up off in tropical places
hanging out with monkeys so if you want
to take off now you can do that but but
you you had your warning that this could
happen but the question I want to start
with is this issue of why would you want
to study monkeys if you care about
humans and I think the way to frame that
is is based on an intuition that I think
you'll get so imagine you're trying to
learn about a human imagine you're
trying to learn about a new person that
you meet for the first time and so I'm
going to get to that by sort of
switching years and actually asking this
question why should we study monkeys to
learn about humans so imagine you're
meeting a person for the first time
let's say you go to a new high school or
those of you who are in high school you
go to a new college for the first time
you're meeting people that aren't just
from new haven or west haven from
Branford people from all around the
world what do you want to ask them to
get to know them for the first time this
is the audience-participation part so
what do you ask them your name you want
to know their name their age something
about how old they are where they're
from exactly so this is that you guys
you are not a plant that's actually what
you see and this is fascinating right I
can be in a group of folks here I've
given this talk all around the world
with the same setup and most of the time
people come up with this pretty quickly
it's usually in the top two or three
things you want to ask somebody where
are you from why do we care well we care
because where somebody's from actually
matters for who they are right now if
you grew up in branford or New Haven we
think your experiences are
to be really different than if you grew
up in Florida or San Francisco or
Thailand where you're where you're from
actually tells me something that's very
Causley relevant for who you are right
now I can learn a lot about you by
figuring out where you came from this is
basically the logic of why we turn to
studying the origins of cognition from
an evolutionary perspective the idea is
if we really want to know where humans
are from why just stop at the
developmental part of just how long your
life course went maybe we can learn
something about where humans are from by
considering an even broader history one
that goes way back into our evolutionary
origins and that's the idea we're going
to be trying to look at our different
cognitive origin sort of where our
cognition and our thinking comes from
because if there's a puzzle to
understanding a person that you meet at
camp or at a new high school there's a
bigger puzzle of trying to get at the
very basis of how we think of things so
all all of you right now have inside
your head the sort of gob of tissue
that's processing all the cool things
that make up your human experience
processing things like aggravation and
bright ideas and storytelling all the
kinds of things that make us us and we
still know remarkably little about how
this works what we try to do is to try
to say well given this is such a big
project maybe we have to get to the
roots of it maybe we have to study its
origins both evolutionarily and also
developmentally because one of the
things my colleagues here at Yale do and
some of you were here a few years ago
you might have seen my colleague Paul
bloom talk about this stuff but one of
the things we can do is to actually try
to figure out the way that adult human
mind works by going back back back
across the developmental couch so my
colleague Paul bloom actually studies
what these super young babies over here
know about the world how do they make
sense of it he finds that they can do
things like make moral decisions and so
on but the point is that you can
actually see the changes over
developmental time as we get older as we
get access to schooling and so on and
that can teach us something about how
schooling and language and culture
shapes the mind in our lab we do the
same thing except rather than taking a
developmental approach we take an
evolutionary approach but the idea is
just the same in an ideal world we'd
study this guy over here we try to see
how does he make sense to the world
given that this is a guy that probably
doesn't have language or culture or any
schools or anything and how did that
change over evolutionary time as we got
to us with all the conveniences of
in life there's a big problem with this
approach though and that it's it's
really hard to find subjects for this
kind of study because most of the guys
we actually want to study are dead
they're not just did they've been dead
for thousands sometimes even millions of
years so we have to come up with a bit
of a proxy some sort of other way to get
at this and that is why we turn to the
primates that we have here living today
here's my student Neha one of my former
undergrads who's now a postdoc but she's
actually turning to non-human primates
to get this answer and so for those of
you who are not familiar with your
primate tree here's a kind of quick
schematic to get you oriented this is
the sort of Yale centric primate tree
and some of you are smiling which means
I think you recognize who this who the
human I'm depicting here is anybody you
want to call out who the george bush
right so we get to make fun of george
bush because he's a Yalie and sometimes
we like to do that but george bush's on
here in part to remind us that evolution
isn't a ladder with humans on top being
the smartest remember for a big tree
we're all equal you know at the tops as
I said he's a Yalie so we get to make
fun of him right but what we try to do
is to kind of compare cognition thinking
across all the top branches of this tree
and in our own lab we actually do this
with the furthest three members of the
primate tree and this gives us a really
wide window into the way primate
cognition works the three different
groups of primates that we've been
working with in our labs start with
these guys here these are the prosimian
primates which branched off from our own
branch about 50 or 60 million years ago
we can kind of quibble about the numbers
but there are most distant set of
primate relatives and we actually study
a group of these guys down at a forest
reserve in a part of florida known as
myakka city it's not very City like
despite the name these are the kinds of
roads you see down in Myakka City but if
you head through the forest you get to a
reserve that's home to about 30
free-ranging lemur species there's a
couple of these ringtail lemur guys they
also have bamboo lemurs these Mongoose
lemurs and some of these brown lemurs
red ruffed lemurs are all very cute but
they get to free range around a 30-acre
enclosure and we can go down there and
actually study them in a relatively
naturalistic habitat so here's some of
my students jen and neha who you saw
before they got yell fellowship money to
actually travel down and work with the
lemurs here's going to Jen getting more
up close and personal and nay
trying to study number in the lemurs
which you'll hear about in a little bit
but this is group one that we study the
most distantly related branch are
primates these lemurs we also study a
second group of primates that's closer
to home both evolutionarily and kind of
spatially these guys are the branch of
primates known as the New World monkeys
because unlike us they actually evolved
in the New World so they're native to
Central and South America we actually
study a group of these guys here on
campus it's a group of brown capuchin
monkeys we have 10 of these guys they
live in a big zoo enclosure and we get
to do behavioral studies with them and
have up close and personal this is a
resource that we have here at Yale to
actually study cognition not so far from
campus so that's the new world monkeys
but as I said we study three branches so
we also study this branch here this is
the branch of old world monkeys the
monkey species that are most closely
related to us and these guys are
represented by the rhesus macaque who's
the species you see here we study a
group of rhesus macaques again in a
naturalistic habitat this is the the
picture that got me wanting to do this
kind of work and you can see why this is
the island of Ko Santiago which is right
off the coast of Puerto Rico it's
gorgeous and this is why my under guys
like to go there to sort of a nice rocky
beach and pretty palm trees but it's
relevant for us because it's home to a
thousand free-ranging rhesus monkeys so
again these rhesus monkeys kind of go
around and do their monkey thing but we
can go down with teams of scientists
here's me and one of my undergrads
genigan we sort of get our stuff
together we could go hiking around the
island following the monkeys watching
their behavior and then also setting up
these kind of thinking tests to sort of
set up some problems and see how monkey
solved them here's my undergrad Brian
Edwards who's now a grad student at
Northwestern sort of asking monkeys
about causality which we might get to a
little bit as well but this is the basic
approach i take trying to compare across
the tops of these different trees to see
what monkeys know oh and just just for
kicks sometimes we present monkeys with
totally crazy things that my undergrads
come up with which you'll see in a
second but you can see the monkeys are
quite fascinated with these things all
right but what I haven't told I've told
you a little bit what I do but I haven't
told you yet is why it actually makes
sense to study monkeys why would you
want to actually turn to monkeys of what
you're interested in is humans and I
think there's two distinct answers to
the question but i'm going to broaden it
up and not just talk about why study
monkeys but why study animals in
because oftentimes even though I focus
on primates the answers might be the
same no matter what animals you actually
turn to as long as there are non-human
species but there's two kinds of answers
here one is the answer that isn't the
flavor of answer that I typically give
as a psychologist it's an answer that a
biologist might give and biologists
might answer the question of why you
want to study animals they might say
well look animal behavior is incredibly
interesting in its own right we might
just want to know how animals do what
they do from the perspective of biology
and we of course implicitly know this of
course no one would spend their time
going on the internet looking at things
like this if what animals did wasn't
sort of funny you know you get this sort
of like wall hats version or sort of
here these sort of funny things I mean
this is a sort of clip right we have
these things on YouTube because animals
do funny things but real animal behavior
is often more impressive and more
intriguing and so to do that I'm
actually gonna I just realize I need to
sort of put my sound on here real fast
i'm going to show you an example of one
of my my favorite cases a very
interesting animal behavior see if we
can get this to a work you guys hearing
the bleeps there no all right we'll see
if we angels just make sure my volume is
up here that sounded good well we'll see
if this works if not I can kind of come
back to it in a sec
all right well it's this
there we go all right so now as I was
saying this is my favorite example of
the coolest animal behavior and as I
said I don't pick a primate because the
primate would be kind of too close to
home these guys very very distantly
related from primates but as you'll see
they're incredibly cool this guy is a
liar bird who's one of the birds that
lives over in Australia and New Zealand
and you can see he has an incredibly
interesting cognitive habit that he uses
to recruit females when he's trying to
mate with them and i'll let the Lyrebird
take it away to persuade females the
[ __ ] close and admire his goons he sings
the most complex on he can manage and he
does that by copying the songs of all
the other birds here's around him such
as the kookaburra it's a very convincing
impersonation even the original is for
all he could imitate the cause of at
least 20 different species he also in
his attempt to I'll sing his rivals
incorporates other signs that he hears
him the forest that was a camera shutter
and again and now a camera with a motor
drive
and now the sound get foresters and
their chainsaws working nearby okay so
you see why ya always sad when the liber
gets more positive me but I understand
why because that is just amazing like
how can you not find that the most
fascinating thing ever and that's not
just some weird like video thing that's
actually what the Lyrebird does the
Lyrebird has to imitate all these kinds
of different calls and somehow he has a
cognitive process that lets him pick up
sounds and imitate them way better than
anybody on like saturday night live or
any human impersonators right and this
sort of leads to these kind of big
questions which is like what is this
lyrebird doing right how is he taking
the sounds that are out there in the
world feeding them through his head and
producing them himself right why is he
doing it why on earth do the females
find this attractive that he sounds like
a chainsaw like that's pretty weird how
is he doing it right like what are the
brain structures that let him translate
this information but here is where their
psychologist I think differs a little
bit from the biologist because this is
the question I come up with which is
like how come we can't do that you know
why is it that we don't have the kinds
of cognitive skills to vocally imitate
in any of the same kinds of ways I think
this is the sort of psychologists turn
whenever they see animals doing
interesting cool things or lacking
certain abilities not doing the kinds of
things that we do is trying to turn to
animals to try to figure out the
psychologists answer which is that what
can animal behavior actually tell us
about us what can we learn about
ourselves about the fact that we can't
do the things that the Lyrebird can do
but that we can do lots of the things
that the Lyrebird can't do such as be up
here discussing animal behavior or
building buildings like this or setting
a PowerPoint slides and so on why is it
that we're so different and the claim is
that if we turn to non-human animals we
could actually learn something very
important about ourselves and I'm going
to start by tell you two things i think
that animal behavior can actually tell
us about ourselves this you'll see
person later this is my colleague Brian
hare who studies that last branch of
primates other than humans the eighth
branch here he is working with one of
his chimpanzee subjects I'm going to
make the claim that we can learn to
separate things from studying animals
the first of the things that I think we
can learn is a really important question
which is what is unique to ourselves
it's obvious that we're a special
species right no other species on the
planet is doing what we're doing right
now but what is it about us that makes
us so unique what makes us so special
and again we have to to worry about this
because we can look to other animals and
realize a lot of things I do look very
similar to what we do you know and I
guess dog food companies kind of make
fun of this you know maybe we're all
bull dogs out there but it raises this
question of what parts of our mind our
special to us what is it that makes us
special now of course we can hypothesize
all kinds of things that might make
especially when we ask this question we
sort of turn to the kinds of things
humans do we say well there are all
these things out there that look pretty
special I mean no other species is using
language like we use it no other species
is using tools in the same way we use it
we have this sort of special culture
where we can pass information on through
generations we develop art and beautiful
kinds of theater and so on and we can
point to these kinds of things and say
you know this is the stuff that kind of
looks like it makes us special fair
enough but if we stop there we might
miss something because to really answer
this question we actually have to ask
whether non-human animals do any of the
stuff like this and when you actually
turn to non-human animals you see all
these cases where they're doing things
that look a lot like what we are doing
we see all kinds of cases of animal tool
use there's evidence the animals can
stand can transmit some information
culturally there's some evidence that
even bees might have something like a
language that's structured in some ways
like our own and there's even evidence
that other animals create and design
things seemingly for just the purpose of
aesthetics and that's the case of the
guy up in that right corner this
bowerbird that i'll tell you about in a
second i'm going to focus on him for a
second just to sort of hit you over the
head with the fact that even though it
looks like what we do is special
sometimes you can find rudiments of this
stuff in the animal kingdom and what the
bowerbird does is the mill bowerbird
faces the same kind of problem as the
Lyrebird you saw before he has to
attract very finicky females to try to
mate with them he doesn't do it through
an elaborate song
he does it through his artistic talent
and what bowerbirds do is they build
what's known as a bower it's kind of
this nest like structure but it's not a
nest nobody's going to live there it
really seems to be a showcase where the
bowerbird can show off various artistic
things he's done such as collected these
beautiful blue objects such as the satin
bowerbird the satin bowerbird likes to
design things using blue things so he
steals blue things from around his
environment and arrange them in very
particular ways and if you were to go up
and remove one of these blue feathers
and move it to another spot what you'd
see is that the bowerbird would replace
it in its same spot so he seems to have
his own aesthetic taste and females pick
which bowerbird to meet with based on
that taste I'll give you a sense of
another bower bird species here's
another short David Attenborough video
that shows another vocal power burger
this is the work of the master builder
among the repairs I'm in the vocal
copper on the far western tip of New
Guinea and this is the power of the
vocal coach barbara and what an
astonishment it is surely one of the
wonders of the natural world the bow has
been completely roofed over thatched
with these stems of orchids it's been
built around the base of this happening
it has a stark pillar right in the
middle and it's got two smaller pillars
on the side to support it the hull of
the Treasury is five or six yards across
and what treasures it contains a variety
of treasures it contains on the far side
there are the black stems of tree ferns
here is the lawn neatly planted with
moss and on it the shiny wing covers are
beetles now orange fruit they're these
glowing orange dead leaves these are the
acorns of the oak trees to topical oaks
which are common around here behind me
that are black fruits all of which has
been bought specially by the bird so you
get this sense that this isn't me this
isn't just some bird kind of putting
stuff together this is an artistic
display area it's got pillars much like
old Greek columns it's got a planted lon
that the bird plants its get specific
colors and specific spots and we could
ask the question is this like human art
you know should we pay as much for a
bower as we do for a Jackson Pollock
painting and probably we wouldn't want
to pay as much for the powers of Jackson
Pollock painting but but why what's
different about it point is we can ask
that question we can think more about
what makes us different but we have to
look at what animals are doing try to
figure out what they actually know to
get there we just assume the animals
don't do anything like us we'd be remiss
we have to turn to them to really get
the right answer to what makes us
special so that's sort of point number
one we can learn from animals the second
point you can learn from animals is I
think that turn into animals in
particular turning to other primates
gives us a powerful tool that I think
physicists haven't even developed
because turning to other animals
particularly other primates can give us
a time machine to look at what thinking
and cognition might have been like back
in the evolutionary day so what do I
mean by that so you saw the sort of
schematic version of our primate tree
here's sort of the branch of the big
prime the rant of the big animal tree
that we're on and one of the things we
might wonder about as we said we can
study living adult humans but what would
we like over evolutionary time you know
what did humans look like back if we
serve scroll back through time over here
say 35 million years ago or 50 million
years ago as I said we can't study those
guys because they're dead but we get
some hints when we start seeing
similarities and differences across the
top of the branch say for example that
we turn to some traits some aspect of
our thinking and we see it's not just us
that does it but it's us and chimpanzees
and rhesus
monkeys and capuchin monkeys and lemurs
let's say we find really robust
similarity across the tree well we've
done i think is to learn something about
the old guy back here we've kind of done
a time machine thing because the
parsimonious explanation isn't that that
trait developed separately five
different times it's probably just
pretty old probably developed way back
here what this allows us is a powerful
tool for looking at what human thinking
looked like way back in very very
evolutionarily old ages and allows us to
ask questions like what parts of what we
do are specific to modern society what
parts of what we do are specific to the
kinds of learning we have in modern
society and what parts are just built in
just super evolutionarily old figuring
that out helps us figure out you know
what we can change around through
education and what we need to change
around through other means so that's the
sort of second big question you can get
at so this advocate question what parts
of the mind are evolutionarily old so
those are the two sort of big things we
can get at turning to animals and
particularly to non-human primates now
I'm going to talk about specific ways
that we've tried to look at how primates
think about the world and have gained I
think some important insights into the
way humans might do it themselves and
the first domain I want to turn to to
ask this question is the domain about
whether or not primates can think about
number in the same way that we do now
here's a spot where we might think that
we are unique to humans right our
species is probably the only species
that does differential equations and
complex calculus and so on we know that
that's probably true but are there
rudiments that we can see in other
species and what parts of mathematics do
we bring to the table are children born
with some propensity to do some aspects
of numerical reasoning or is it all
built up through training and teaching
and culture and so this is what we've
been looking at a little bit and what
other researchers have been looking at
by trying to see whether or not
non-human animals in this case the
rhesus monkeys down in our field site
can actually count different numbers of
objects and so you might be thinking to
yourself you know how on earth can you
ask this question now how can we ask
monkeys whether what they know about
number unlike what happens in six or 7th
grade we can't give you a math we can
give the monkeys a math test because
they don't talk so we have to come up
with some other creative kinds of means
to get at what they're actually thinking
about what they know about in the world
and the way we do it you saw a little
bit in some of the pictures that I was
showing you about neha and brian and
others showing monkeys these sort of
strange displays of different kinds of
objects what were they doing there well
it turns out we figured out an excellent
way to ask monkeys about their
intuitions about the world and we use a
technique that might be a little bit
shocking but we actually use magic not
magic in the kind of you know we we fake
it hocus pocus we actually use magical
events to get at their knowledge of the
world so what on earth do I mean by this
well think about a magician that you
might have seen recently I always choose
David Copperfield's I think he's my
favorite musician you will pay you know
50 bucks a pop to go to the you know
Civic Center to see David Copperfield do
all these kinds of things right why are
we willing to pay to go see David
Copperfield to do this stuff well one of
the things that David Copperfield is
good at doing is he's very good at
violating our intuitions about the way
the world works so it's cool to pay to
see David Copperfield sort of split
himself in half with a big saw because
you know something about how human
bodies work you know human bodies note
sort of pop in half and come back
together that would be very weird for
human bodies you also know something
about the way physical objects work they
don't float in air without a string
attaching them somewhere that looks
really weird to us and then two things
happen one is that we kind of enjoy
watching these events which is why we
pay money to go see David Copperfield
the second is that we get a little bit
surprised by them and that causes us to
watch them for a really long time as
some of you guys are doing I'm seeing
the sort of phases where you're looking
trying to see their string like is that
like you know a false bottom you're
trying to figure out the trick but
you're only find a trick you're only
trying to figure out the trick because
you know that human bodies don't work
like that that the physical world
doesn't work like that you have an
expectation you have knowledge in your
head about something and we can use
magic to tap it so that's the logic of
doing monkey magic well we're able to do
with the monkeys is actually give them
magical addition events where one plus
one doesn't equal what you expect we're
going to try to see whether or not the
monkeys can do that really well and I
have up here a sort of version of of
what we do i'll show you the non magical
event and then I might need a volunteer
from the audience to help me with some
fake monkey magic and remember the
monkeys aren't as
savvy as you guys are so this is not
david copperfield you know it was free
for you guys to get in so don't expect a
fifty dollar show we can show the
monkeys events where we actually show
them something about how addition works
so we can show them and adding different
numbers of objects we can do one pair
like this and then we can sort of put
down a screen and ask your expectations
about if we put a second pair down in
here and then we can lift the screen and
show you events that look like this
where one plus one equals one or we
could show you magical events so does
anybody want to help me with a magical
event I grabbed you because I saw you
first yeah oh well I love you guys help
next time so so I need to what's your
name I'm not that nice to meet you so
I'm going to whisper you have to talk
about yourself so I wistar to anomic out
how the magic works and so i'm going to
show you want to try all right so all
right so we're going to add one to the
stage all right she's adding one and
then we're going to put the screen down
you're going to add a second one and add
a second one make sure it goes on there
very good and ready for the big o song
song one plus one equals one thank you
as I said the monkey magic is not as
magical some of you over there seeing
the trick but you know but to the
monkeys this is pretty shocking because
they're watching one go in there seeing
me add a second one really quickly and
then I lift it and there's only one
there so question is do the monkeys
notice this are they shocked by it and
this is there so we're able to do here's
how it looks when we run it in our field
site sorry to keep moving the lights
around but what you what we have is we
have one person who's doing the kind of
thing that we were just doing up here
where they're the magician they're
putting objects into these boxes and
running the magic importantly we have a
camera person who's just filming what
happens with the monkeys do they get
surprised did they look for a long time
and all importantly we have the monkey
who's sitting there who's watching the
event and we're videotaping his reaction
and we come back to the lab later we
just measure as a measure of surprised
how long he watches it is he shocked
enough to watch
for a long time and they just see events
like the one you saw so we'd add one egg
plant to a box oops one egg plant to a
box hide it up and then add a second
eggplant and we show either expected
events where one plus one equals two or
unexpected events in which one plus one
equals one and the expectation is when
we show the monkeys expected events this
should be really boring we should get
videotapes that look like this monkeys
are yawning they're just not into this
at all versus cases where one plus one
equals one and here we expect videotapes
that look like this where the monkeys
are shocked marvel Dena here they're
happy to pay 50 bucks to see this but
what we've been able to do with this
sort of technique is to actually show
that monkeys know something about very
simple arithmetic so in the top case
here where one eggplant at the top plus
one eggplant equals two we see that on
average the monkeys look for about one
second and so you know a reasonable look
but they're not that shocked what
happens in the case as envie where one
plus one equals only one we find three
to four times that amount of looking so
monkeys stare for three to four seconds
again they're not so shocked that this
is blowing them away but we see a
difference you just seem they understand
that something was wrong from the
arithmetic that they know in that case
same thing when you have one plus one
equals two big a number like 3 again we
see these three to four seconds of
looking and so I'll show you a quick
video of what this looks like it I
apologize the quality of this video is
not great but it'll give you some idea
of what it looks like to run these
studies down at the field type using a
portable magic stage Laurie and Sue are
now investigating whether the monkeys
can also do basic addition the
experiment works like this a lime is
placed on the stage and a barrier put
down to block the view after a brief
pause another lime is added one plus one
is two no magic there the monkey quickly
loses interest
it's videotaped to measure later how
long the monkey look now here's another
show it's identical to the first except
for the surprise ending watch ready one
plus one equals one ya the monkey stares
for a long time many seconds more than
before sue believes this means the
monkey was surprised that it must have
known something was wrong such looking
time experiments as they're called were
actually developed to figure out what's
going on inside the minds of human
babies when shown non magical events
like this 13 month old babies get bored
rapidly but show them an impossible or
magical event like this the infants
stare and stare the fascination with
magical events suggests they know the
world doesn't work this way so the point
is we can actually use magic in some
cases to get at what monkeys know and
what we did this in the case of number
what we found is that monkeys seem to
have some of the rudiments that we do
they do the kinds of basic arithmetic
you see early on in human development
and it turns out with future work we
found that monkeys can exactly compute
arithmetic up to about 4 and then they
do pretty good even with big numbers if
you give them big ratios so they'd know
if something like five plus five is more
likely to be ten than five they sort of
be surprised at five but maybe not at
eight so on so we're getting to the
rudiments of these basic arithmetic
abilities in the monkeys but one of the
things we saw when we are running these
studies ended up launching a new line of
investigation and this is is relevant to
tell you guys about because sometimes
the progress in science you think it's
the way you read about in textbooks
where you have a hypothesis you think
about the question it's kind of the way
you sort of see the scientific method in
a book the way the scientific method
really works in the field is that you
have some observations someone expect
did thing happens and this gets you to
start thinking about wait a minute like
what was going on there it generates new
questions and then you can ask these new
questions and so this is what launched
some of the work that we started trying
to see what monkeys knew about other
minds and it happened in an unfortunate
incident somewhat like this where we're
testing the monkeys we've got our little
fruits that the monkeys might watch sort
of lifting the screen and all the time
when we end we do the thing that you see
me doing up there which is we don't want
to kill the monkeys so we just slightly
turn to decide so we're no longer
looking of course that also means we
don't know what's happening with our box
and if potentially a monkey who wanted
to steal the fruit was about to do that
so this is what one of the videos
looking for hey hey hey hey you and
that's bad camera people trying to
prevent a monkey from running off with
our eggplants which unfortunately
happened so we had to go home early that
day because we didn't have any more
fruits to do our magic and and that was
very sad but it was exciting because
what we realized was it something was
going on because the monkey seemed like
in these cases where they did this to be
smart about deceiving us only when we
didn't know what was going on only when
we weren't looking so we asked the
question well maybe the monkeys actually
no not just something about arithmetic
not just something about the way numbers
work in physical things work maybe they
know something about how other minds
work maybe they're tracking something
about what's going on inside our heads
and it turns out that if you think about
how hard this problem is it's actually
trickier than you might think so it's
tricky in part because we seem to do it
very easily we forget how difficult it
is so if you saw this image in this
world of this girl with her eyes pointed
at the cookies you would immediately
think certain things about what's going
on inside her head so what are the some
of the things you might think when you
see this picture she wants the cookies
just yeah she wants to steal the cookies
which means something else it's not just
she wants the cookies but she knows
maybe her parents don't want her to take
the cookies and she's trying to do
something when her parents don't know
that she has the cookies look how
complicated this is what you have just
done by thinking about this is thinking
about not something that's in the world
and behavior you're making hypotheses
about what's going on inside her head
not just her head the head of somebody
that's not even in the frame so
mother who's you know somewhere maybe
monitoring this it turns out that this
is computationally an incredibly tricky
process how do we take just what's in
the world and develop theories about
intentions and desires and beliefs and
knowledge we never have direct access to
that we probably do it in part because
we're helped by language we have words
like no and intend and believe in desire
that helps us probably figure this stuff
out but what about a nonhuman animal
that lacks language that doesn't have
those words could they ever think about
what's going on inside somebody's head
do they know what it means for somebody
to see something and they sort of fill
in that box up there well a lot of
researchers have tried to look at this
and I'll start with some work in
chimpanzees by my colleague Brian hare
and part because he's done some of the
pioneering work in this area and also
some of the loveliest brian works with a
set of apes he works both with
chimpanzees and bonobos who are on the
eighth branch he works with them out in
a sanctuary in Africa and this is just a
short public service announcement which
is that even though the monkeys and the
Apes that you see in this setup are cute
you should never have one as a pet and
the reason you should never have one as
a pet is sort of shown by where Brian
actually does his work this is a
sanctuary in Africa and its home mostly
two very young chimpanzees and the
reason is that these are all orphaned
chimpanzees orphan because their parents
were killed in order to capture them for
the pet trade the ones that Brian has it
the thank you are ones that were caught
at the airport but they were all being
moved over to the states to be pet and
so this is sad these are these orphans
parents are getting killed do not have a
chimpanzee as a pet it's dangerous and
it's kind of ethically a little bit
sketchy but this is the spot where Brian
actually works it's this lovely
sanctuary in Africa the apes get to free
range around and when they're interested
in coming in to do testing they can come
into an enclosure inside and sort of
play with Brian for some treats so
typically they live outside they come
into these enclosures here are some
videos about what it looks like when the
chimps are in the enclosure and brian is
going to be running a study here to ask
whether the chimpanzees actually know
something about what he can see and so
i'll give you it's going to be a video
in a sec but i just want to set it up
for a bit here's a cam of brian he's
sort of sitting there on this side the
top left is what's happening on the left
of where Brian is and that's what's
happening on the right and Ryan setting
up a study where there's this delicious
juice that yo haga this chimpanzee wants
but he's trying to convince her that
he's a scary dominant competitor and
that she can't take it so it's kind of
like with a kid with the cookies and no
mom so Brian's being the mom Brian
saying no you're not allowed to take the
juice right now and you can sort of see
what happens here where yo haga the
chimpanzee tries to go to the side and
get that little bottle of juice and
bronze like no it's like the mom you
can't take the cookies and so y haga
runs the other side maybe he won't see
me on the other side but Brian's like no
I'm gonna follow you there too and she
runs the other side and so this is like
what's fun about working with primates
then yeah how get this funny things like
roll on the ground but the point is that
Brian gets good about teaching her he's
gonna be like the mom he doesn't want
her to take the juice question is are
the chimpanzees savvy like that little
girl about taking the cookies when
nobody's watching and what you can see
is exactly the same setup except this
time Brian's put up this big opaque
barrier so now it's not clear anymore
it's colored which means that if she
were to try to sneak to that side to
steal the juice Brian might not be able
to see her and so Brian because this is
his experiment he sort of freeze framing
and letting her do her thing and see she
kind of thinks about it looks like she's
thinking about it for a second time it
goes off to the side and for a while she
sort of is thinking about it so much
that she goes back to the outside she's
no longer in the closure you know
Brian's freeze friend me and this is
where if Brian was savvy with these
videos he put in some sort of Mission
Impossible music or likes behind music
because what happens is yo haga very
quietly sneaks back and she's very
excited about this because she's figured
out what to do she's going to sneak to
the side that Brian has and actually get
the juice so they're on the first trial
they're very smart about this they use
barriers to block what people can see do
they also understand not just seeing but
things like intentions and that's
something else that Brian was up to with
a different chimpanzee here Brian's
actually doing a study where he's just
normally doing what he would do with
just adore feed yo hago treats when she
comes inside to play these games but all
of a sudden he stops doing that so the
outcome is going to be bad in all these
cases he's not going to give her treats
anymore either because he is a good
intention but he just can't act on it
he's trying to give her food but he's
becoming clumsy he keeps dropping things
and that's going to be the first case
versus a case where he has a bad
intention so what's going on in his head
is bad he's going to be trying to tease
her
and all of you know that who have kids
know that the kids pick up on this easy
if you have really younger siblings you
know younger siblings are good at
figuring out whether your intentions are
good or bad what about chimpanzees so
here's a case where he's being he's has
good intentions good things in his head
but he's just become clumsy this video
looks like it's getting stuck a bit but
you can see what happens which is that
yo haga just hangs out here she was sort
of waiting for him to overcome his
clumsiness he's like sorry sorry but his
intentions are good so she doesn't react
badly to this what happens in the case
where his intentions are bad and so this
is the case of teasing so it looks the
same she's still not going to get the
food but haha he teases her and she says
no very very different reaction she's
out of there she's going back to hang
out with her crew she doesn't want to
play the game anymore right this is
relevant because the behavior is the
same she's not getting food in both
cases but the chimps are picking up on
what's going on inside someone's head
what about the case of more distantly
related primates such as our monkeys
down at the field site well we wanted to
do the same kind of thing with our
monkeys and as you saw from the looking
time studies that I was showing you
before the monkey seemed pretty good at
stealing from us when we weren't looking
so we said well let's just set up an
experiment on this so we brought down to
other undergrads who go down to the
field site in this case they're going to
be like Brian they're going to be the
moms who are competing against these
monkeys for food they each stand in
front of a little platform with a grape
and the question is which one do the
monkeys actually steal and you probably
guess since the monkeys will get at this
before that the monkeys might be good at
this one here's just a short video so
you can see it isn't looking so we put
the platform down we're all looking and
then one person turns away and you can
see the monkeys run up and take the food
so turns out the monkeys are really
savvy at this I'll show you some grass
basically I'm just going to plot the
black bars or how many monkeys get it
right well you can see when the person's
head is just turned not even their whole
back turn but just their head turn most
of the monkeys get it right they even
get it right if you're just looking away
so you just turn away briefly they get
it right and even when you give these
kind of weird novel barriers they figure
it out they seem to be thinking about
what's going on inside someone's head
which is really really cool we also were
able to show with another set of under
eyes this is Aaron who's down there at
the field site that the monkeys know
about something about what it means to
hear and so this time we're going to be
putting food not on these flat platforms
but inside these weird boxes the boxes
are transparent so the monkeys can see
what's in them but what's relevant is
that they're covered in these golden
jingle bells and so as Aaron's putting
the food in one of these boxes the
monkeys can actually hear that this box
is making a lot of noise as he's putting
food in its making a lot of noise
probably not a good box to steal because
the person might hear you the second box
looks exactly the same it's visually
it's identical but we've taken the balls
outside of the little jingle bells so
even though it looks the same the
monkeys can hear when the person is
putting when Aaron's putting food in
there that this box is totally quiet so
now the boxes are loaded Aaron steps
back and he just looks away for a little
bit any question is what we think the
monkeys are going to do which one are
they going to steal from the quat the
quiet one right and this is just what we
find when you plot how many monkeys
steal from things they actually steal
from the silent one so on the first
trial they get it these totally novel
bells and all this stuff they steal from
the one that you can't hear but we gave
them one more hard problems now
everything was the same except this time
when Aaron steps back he can already see
what's going on so what he can hear
doesn't matter because he can already
see what do you think the monkeys are
going to do here are they going to do
the same thing or something different
something different very good and that's
actually what we find here the monkeys
don't show that same preference if
anything they kind of go to the noisy
one that's because probably all things
being well the monkeys like to make a
bit of a ruckus they like being a little
bit noisy over time but the point is is
that means that the monkeys are thinking
about the very thoughts that are going
on inside our head they know something
about what it means to see and hear they
actually use that to deceive us so they
don't use this always for the nicest
purposes they seem to get this thing
which is computationally really tricky
you can think about what we're thinking
so the hell is test case number 2 i'm
going to end with test case number 3
which is some recent work that we've
been up to trying to see whether the
monkeys know something about what it
means to use money and we started this
work in like a few years ago right
around the time of the financial
collapse where I was in my lab talking
to my students using humans is the sort
of paragon of how smart we are reserved
the benchmark against which were testing
our monkeys and then I would go home and
watch the news and see who
is doing incredibly stupid things with
their finances watching traders make
errors watching banks do these silly
things I said we'll hang on there's a
little bit of a disconnect here these
bankers and investors and folks have
lots of experience they still seem to be
doing things that might not be so smart
we said well maybe it's just like number
or this idea of how we reason about
minds maybe there's something built in
to the kind of errors that we make with
money and so this launch the kind of
work that we've been up to with our
capuchin monkeys here yeah we've been
trying to see if we can actually teach
the monkeys to use something like money
and then see what they do with it do
they do the smart things that humans do
and do they make the same kinds of
errors now we couldn't give the capuchin
monkeys five dollar bills because they
might tear those up so we had to have
something a little bit more durable but
we made our own aluminum capuchin coins
we sort of made our own sort of Capuchin
money kind of boring didn't have the
sort of flashy look of some countries
money but they kind of got it we sort of
introduced these coins to them and then
we allowed them to trade them with
people for pieces of food and our
monkeys are very curious as soon as you
put these things in there like what are
these things they immediately pick them
up and if there's a person waiting with
food they kind of get very quickly oh I
can do the swap as soon as they pick
this up basically we had a monkey market
that we could use to ask these kinds of
questions so here's made a one of our
monkeys monkeys she has her little
monkey money at first we used metal
washers and then we said upgraded to
this new currency but she quickly gets
as she can hand over these things with
humans and here's another kind of
slightly more French New Wave version
video of this here's Felix who's one of
our or hears Mayday again she hands over
the token and gets her food so she gets
good at this here's Felix who's our
alpha male he's a big guy hands over the
toe can get through alright so they get
very very good at this and the question
is does this just look like using a
currency or are they really paying
attention to the kinds of things that
would matter for humans using a currency
for example do they pay attention to how
much food they get for their dollar as
it were do they pay attention to price
and these sorts of things so we want you
into a whole series of studies to set to
show this and I won't have time to go
through them all but I'll just give you
a flavor of what we found suggesting
that the monkeys get this market it
works in the same way as human markets
do now rather than trade with one
experimenter the monkeys are going to
get
choice between two different
experimenters so they get to kind of
leave their enclosure they come into the
spot where they can trade with the
humans and then they actually get a
choice so the monkeys can trade with
Kirk who seems like he's offering one
grape sort of in this dish that's what
the monkeys think they're going to get
or they could trade with Justin who has
two grapes and a question is if you are
a savvy Capuchin chopper would you shop
with Kirk in the red or adjusted in the
purple you stop with Justin all right
let's see let's see what the monkeys do
so here's a video this is kind of a
monkey I've you here's honey one of our
monkeys she started waiting for the
markets open because you only get chest
level the monkey eye view but the market
opens and she checks out her choice one
grape or two grapes who's she going to
shop with she shops with Justin so very
savvy monkey consumer most of our
monkeys shopped with Justin at about
rates of seventy to eighty percent and
this was not the only smart thing they
did this is paying attention to who
gives you overall more food the monkeys
cared about price so if all of a sudden
Justin dropped his price and the way we
do that with the monkeys is the price is
always one token but you can get more
food it's kind of like when you go and
get big laundry detergent you get the
extra for free that's actually cheaper
laundry detergent so we did this we're
Justin or a Kirkwood had a decrease or
increase their prices the monkeys
responded rationally to all these things
in other words they correctly shocked at
the guys who gave them better deals so
it seemed like the monkeys in all these
cases we're doing smart things with
monkey monkey monkey and money sounds
way too similar but they do smart things
with money the question is whether they
do some of it not so smart things that
humans do and just to see a flavor of
some of these not so smart things I'll
have you guys play in a money experiment
that's known to elicit some people's
bias II so imagine that science
Saturday's gets enormous endowment for
some rich alum and I'm able to offer you
guys not just really cool science for
free but a thousand dollars for coming
to science Saturday's I bet every seat
here would be full if we did this but
sadly again but imagine you just get a
thousand dollars right so this is the
game we're going to play and really play
along like if you had a thousand dollars
right now what would you do with it what
would you buy but it's not just a
thousand dollars you have a chance to
earn more money you either get a choice
to take a risk so we're going to gamble
I'm going to flip a coin and if it
comes up heads you're going to get a
thousand dollars more or if it comes up
tails you get nothing so that's your
first choice or you could just play it
safe and you could just take an extra
five hundred dollars from science
saturday for sure you don't have to flip
a coin and so again audience
participation who goes with the take a
risk one good who goes with the play it
safe a lot more people and that's
actually what you find when you test
people with this setup most of the
people around seventy percent choose to
play it safe that's not irrational I
just shows were little risk averse
what's irrational is what happens when
you give people a slightly different
version of the same scenario so now
imagine that we gave you two thousand
dollars for science Saturday this seems
even better but it turns out it's
actually kind of bad because the choice
you have to make is how to lose some of
the two thousand dollars you just got
you have to give some of it back you
could either give it back in a gamble
where I'm going to flip a coin and if it
comes up heads that's very bad you have
to give me a thousand dollars or you
could keep it if you are lucky and it
comes up tails or you could choose to
play it safe where you just have you
don't have to take the gamble you just
give me five hundred dollars back with
certainty and those of you who are good
at math might be figuring out well hang
on that is exactly the same as what
happened there it's either $1,500 for
sure or a thousand or two thousand if
you go risky and some of you are smiling
which I think means that you're getting
the intuition which is it when you see
the problem like this what happens is
most people don't want to play it safe
anymore in this case what happens is
most people want to be risky they want
the chance that they're not going to
lose any money and can keep the whole
thing this is totally irrational because
what it means is you have a different
risk preference just based on what you
started with which doesn't actually
matter for what you get in the end it's
an example of all the kinds of biases
that we see that plague the market right
now and what we wanted to do is to see
whether we could see the same kinds of
biases in the monkeys just to sort of
put it in perspective to give you a
sense of what these biases are what you
just showed in that scenario if you felt
that intuition we're two biases The
Economist's find very funny the first
bias is what economists sometimes refer
to as reference points economist
sometimes think that when you're making
choices about your money what you should
think about is the only absolutes how
much wealth overall you have or how much
happiness you can get overall that's
just not how people
think if you were to leave here from
science Saturdays and walk out to your
car and saw that you had a parking
ticket from the New Haven your parking
ticket office you probably wouldn't look
at that parking ticket and calculate
what's in your bank account right now
minus the parking ticket you wouldn't
think in terms of absolute you'd
probably say some expletive maybe cover
your children's ears and say twenty
dollars like I was just up twenty
dollars before and now I'm down and this
is the this is the this is the power of
reference points we don't think in terms
of absolutes we think in terms of the
status quo a certain reference point as
it were and we see changes relative to
that so when you guys started with a
thousand dollars getting a safe bet
seemed good when you start with two
thousand dollars and you're going into
the red you behave very differently and
the going into the red behavior is the
second bias that economists talk about
it's a bias known as loss aversion we
really don't like going into the red we
really don't like losses and sometimes
that causes us to do strange things to
avoid them like taking on more risk than
we might normally like turns out we
gamble more when we're dealing with
losses just as you guys did in that
scenario so how do we translate this
into asking the same questions for the
monkeys what we wanted to do is give the
monkeys exactly the same survey as you
guys just took before but how do we do
that well we reasoned is that the
monkeys we could actually start sort of
give the monkeys a thousand or give the
monkeys 2000 by varying what the
different experimenters actually started
with so here's starting with a low
amount and both experimenters are going
to give you more it's like the first
scenario Vlad who's on the left here he
has actually the safe guy so every time
the monkey trades with him even though
he starts with one he actually gives two
so this is like getting five hundred
dollars with certainty you're going to
get more small amount but you know
you're going to get it because Vlad does
the same thing every time what about
Wesley well Wesley is very risky
sometimes you just get one so sometimes
you get no gain but sometimes you get a
big gain and you get three so this is
exactly if you're paying attention is
exactly the same scenario we gave to you
guys and this is the monkeys choice do
they want to get a safe gain with Vlad
all the time or do they want to take a
risk and what you guys did was you want
to play it safe what do we think the
monkeys did well exactly what you guys
did they want to actually play it safe
in this case they trade more with Vlad
but what happens when the monkeys are
getting less
and they expect and so this is how we do
the less than they expect both
experimenters are showing the monkeys
more food than they're going to get they
actually take some of the food away and
i can tell you none of our experimenters
like taking the food away from monkeys
they feel very bad about it the monkeys
respond to these losses very sharply and
so here's when the monkeys get a safe
loss from Alex on the left the monkeys
think they're going to get three but
Alex always takes own away to give the
monkeys again a good bet he's giving
them to but every single time he takes
one away what about Venkat he's a risky
loss sometimes he doesn't take any way
but sometimes he takes a lot away to
give them one key only one so you should
see this as very familiar it's exactly
the same choice between two for sure or
risky one or three that the monkeys got
before but now the monkeys are losing
what you guys did here was you became
more risky question is what do the
monkeys do exactly the same thing as you
do here they actually shot more than cat
because sometimes they have a chance not
to get any loss at all it's exactly the
same bias we see in the monkeys seems to
play out in human markets in that in the
housing crisis on the golf course and
even in the case of stocks where people
don't invest enough in stocks that
sometimes dip down all these biases we
see in real markets we see in the
monkeys as well and what this is allowed
us to learn is that something about the
way we deal with money seems to be
shared across a bunch of species maybe
it's not just that we're all bad and
have had difficult experiences with
money where we don't get it maybe
something about these strategies might
be built in interestingly from the start
and so that's the work that we've been
up to with the monkey money and now I
kind of want to wrap up quickly about
what all this stuff means so did what
all this stuff means for the fact that
the monkeys use money for the fact that
they can count a little bit for the fact
that they reason about other minds well
I think what this means is that we've
learned something about what's uniquely
human it seems like none of these things
are specific just to us the second thing
we've learned is something about our
evolutionary time machine what we've
been able to see is it's not just humans
that show these smart capacities or
these biases you see some of these and
rhesus monkeys is in the case of the
work on mines and in the work on number
we see some of this and the capuchin
monkeys is in the case on number may
think what this is done is allowed us to
kind of figure out something about the
guy that was back here seems like this
guy might have known something perhaps
about number something about the
strategies that we use when we're
dealing with money it seems like all of
these things are much more old than we
might have thought before and if you
want in the discussion we can talk about
what does that mean when we're dealing
with biases or some of these other
capacities but it means that we've
answered this interesting question about
what comes to us from the start some of
the things we might not have expected
initially and so that's where we kind of
wanted to stop but I wanted to sort of
end with a little bit of an
advertisement because if you're like me
as i sat in auditorium and heard this
stuff and saw the beautiful palm trees
I'm hoping that I'm getting you excited
about these kinds of questions and it
might feel a little bit frustrating
especially for some of you who are
younger you maybe someday you'll come VL
and work in my lab and head off to these
fabulous places but you might have a few
years in there before you can actually
do this stuff so what can you do if you
really want to study animals but you're
not you don't have access to monkeys or
lemurs or Apes like these guys here what
I want to submit to you is that you guys
probably have the opportunity to use
some of these techniques yourself well
what do I mean by this well you don't
maybe have access to cue monkeys and
tropical places but I bet at least some
of you have access to a population that
might be interesting to study you know
perhaps guys like this or guys like cats
or gerbils or this sort of thing what
I've shown you is a couple techniques
that yes they work on monkeys but
there's no reason that you can't use the
same techniques to try to get it where
your own pets understand about the world
well how would you do this well you just
do the same kinds of science with your
pets that we do here you can see for
example if your dog understands
something about number well how do you
do that well you know you have to invest
the four dollars or so and this little
cardboard thing if some of you want to
take or i can let one person take this
one home with the pairs but you can just
do something like this with your own
dogs out there instead of a lemur you'd
have a dog you probably don't want to
use lemons or fruit maybe some toy that
the doggies like but you can do the same
kind of magical event that i just showed
i will reveal my secret of how it works
for those of you who didn't already
figure it out but what you can just do
is do the same thing we do your
videotape your dogs or just time how
long they look do your dogs actually
understand arithmetic can they be better
than the monkeys you have the tools to
actually ask this question you can try
to see whether they show the same
pattern that we see a monkeys you can
also do the same thing of trying to
figure out if your dogs or cats actually
understand some
about the way the minds work what we saw
is an incredibly simple technique where
if you have something that your dogs
might not want you to take you can sort
of set it up just like this instead of a
monkey you could use dog try to see if
the dogs actually know something about
which ones you know about or which ones
you don't know about the cool thing is
that all the techniques I've shown you
aren't things like particle accelerators
or complicated tools there's just a
bunch of cardboard in little pieces of
food you guys can start being scientists
today if you have pets at home and maybe
you'll learn very very new things about
the way the animal mind works so I hope
I've convinced you that studying the way
humans work can be achieved for this
evolutionary approach through trying to
look as far across the evolutionary tree
as we can and with that I will sort of
end with two things one is to thank my
students who can't be here you've seen
many of them in the talk but I always
tell people that I'm this monkey over
here and I get to sort of sit there and
all the science kind of happens with the
hard work of all my students who you've
seen in the in this talk but I also want
to end with an advertisement if you're
into this stuff and you're around the
area you have this wonderful resource
right here at Yale where we actually
have the capacity to study primate
cognition here on campus and we're also
affiliated with all these cool fun
tropical places where you can study
primates too and that's it and I can
pause for any questions
you